I turns out that this i has an interesting pattern to it. We can simply any
power of i by following this pattern. First, we need to remember that i equals
the square root of negative 1. This means if we square i, we also square the
square root of negative 1. So i squared would equal negative 1. To find the
value of i cubed, we multiply i squared by i. Since the value of i squared is
negative 1, we simply have negative 1 times i, or negative i. So we know i
cubed really simplifies to negative i. So let's use a similar approach to find
i to the 4th. We'll split it up into two powers of i that we know, i squared
and i squared. Since i squared equals negative 1, we have negative 1 twice.
Negative 1 times negative 1 equals positive 1. So i to the 4th will just
simplify to positive 1. Let's see if you can extend our pattern. What do you
think i to the 5th, i to the 6th, i to the 7th, and i to the 8th would be? If
you get the square root of negative 1, I want you to just enter i for your
answer. And as a hint to get you started, you can rewrite i to the 5th as i to
the 4th times i. Think about if you can replace any of these values.